welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat
series i am your host greg knuckles and
i am joined today
by a special temporary guest host eric
trexler
eric how are you doing i'm doing great
uh thank you for the
opportunity how are you doing i am doing
well
um let's let's hop right into things i
reckon
um so there is another podcast where my
special guest host for today
eric trexler hosts i have occasionally
been a guest host onset podcast it's
called the stronger by science podcast
and there is a good news segment
that we've used at the start of
several of our well several of his
recent uh stronger by science podcasts
and as i understand it there is an
update
to one of the prior bits of good news
that you shared with the audience
absolutely i like to think of myself as
a journalist first
and uh a scientist second and a fitness
professional third so
as a journalist i wanted to make sure we
we provided an update here
and one of our listeners actually sent
me this update which is pretty cool so a
while ago i mentioned
that a young woman named eleanor lalu i
think that's the the correct
pronunciation
she was running for um a position
in the municipal government in a town in
northern france
and she has down syndrome and one of the
reasons she wanted to run was to make
sure that someone in the the government
there was advocating for people
with a variety of disabilities and the
good news update is that she got elected
which is pretty sweet so so she's now on
the municipal council there
and by all accounts doing a terrific job
hell yeah
that is good to hear all right so uh
if you haven't listened to a fireside
chat before
these are kind of like off topic
q a type discussions so
anything is fair game other than fitness
questions
so you know listeners send in questions
or topics they'd like us to talk about
and today we have several
picked out and the one we're going to
start with is a listener
asked what our take is on the open
science
movement do you want to lead off i do
but before i get into my take on it do
you want to give the listeners a
general idea of what the open science
movement is
yeah so the the open science movement is
is less like an organization
i guess and more just kind of an
orientation
towards how one would approach
the scientific process and interact with
it so
kind of the traditional process
of academic science for most of the 20th
century
and you know up until today has been
that basically every part of the process
is kind of opaque and cordoned off
so you know like researchers collect
data
no one sees that data except for the
people who are actually writing it up
and publishing it
peer reviewers do peer reviews but then
their peer reviews aren't accessible to
the readers
so you know only only the authors
know what the peer reviewers had to say
um
journals are behind paywalls so
if you don't have institutional access
it's difficult to
access scientific articles um and
basically everything is just kind of
behind pay walls or not accessible or
very very opaque
and the open science movement is kind of
an effort
to bring all of those things more into
the open
so you know things like pre-registering
um pre-registering like study methods
and analysis plans
beforehand so people can like go back
and check like hey did they actually
collect the data the way they said they
were going to
and analyze it the way they said they
were going to
another aspect is open data so if you
publish a scientific article
you have to make your data available and
the code you used to statistically
analyze it available
another big thing is pre-print servers
so before
so like you know you collect your data
you write it up and then before you
actually submit it to a journal
you basically write it up as if you are
about to submit it and then upload
it for free to a preprint server so your
peers in your area
can have a chance to read it before it's
published
give you feedback on it etc so basically
it's it's just a movement
whose intention is to take a lot of the
kind of cordoned off and opaque parts of
the scientific process
and try to make them more open and
accessible and transparent
yeah so when i think about the open
science movement
um you know i i think of really just the
overall process of how peer review works
you know what i mean um and i will be
transparent my faith in the peer review
process right now is at an all-time low
uh within the last two weeks alone
i've been sent the three most ridiculous
papers i've ever seen in my entire life
um and the funny thing about
that happening so uh you sent me two of
them and somebody else sent me a third
and these were papers that it was not in
the fly-by-night journals that no one's
ever heard of
we're talking about journals that are
indexed in pubmed
and all three of these articles i looked
at the title and i said well that's the
most ridiculous thing i've ever seen
and then i looked at the abstract and i
said no that's the most ridiculous thing
i've ever seen
and the interesting thing about all
three of these papers is
they were sent to me i'm not an expert
in any of those topics and
immediately i knew they were ridiculous
and they were so ridiculous that they
essentially went viral
and within the two weeks that they were
sent to me all three of them were either
retracted
or the journal said hey we are going to
retract this we're in the process
and so i think that begs the question
if if me as a
if i as a non-expert took a look at the
title and said this is the dumbest thing
i've ever seen
what the hell did the peer review
process do for those papers
you know what i mean if it was such a
ridiculous premise that it went viral
because of how insane it was
yeah so just just for context here
uh you know we're not talking something
like
oh a paper was published showing that
calories
actually don't matter for change in body
weight or something like
something that is clearly wrong but like
you know maybe someone just had some
anomalous data that they wrote up
whatever
we're talking [ __ ] like there's a black
hole in the middle of the earth
that is using like alien dna to
communicate with the dna in our cells
and that's
doing something yeah and that was
completely off the wall
[ __ ] and that was on pubmed right
yeah yeah
it was in a journal that is pubmed
indexed that is at least theoretically
peer-reviewed
yeah and so i think one of the things
that i find to be really
troubling with the peer review process
currently is like you said a lot of the
processes are opaque
and we are basically funneling the
entire decision making process
down to usually two people
and you know you'll hear stories of
researchers who tried to publish a paper
eight times
and then the ninth time a journal
accepted it
and part of me would like to believe
that that process
those eight or nine iterations of the
paper were them receiving
very good nuanced constructive criticism
them addressing it improving the paper
and moving on to the next journal
but part of me wonders if it's just
reshuffling the deck
you know so so in psychology they had
the replication crisis right and part of
that was
part of the reasons that some of their
results weren't reproducing well
and being replicated effectively was
some of the studies
can be done so quickly and so easily
with minimal resource
input that you could run an online
survey
didn't get what you thought run it again
reshuffle the deck
and in in a different way but kind of
analogous way
i kind of wonder with some of these like
that when the peer review process
is opaque you can just keep reshuffling
the deck of reviewers
until you get the two who just can't be
bothered to look at it
and will just accept something like that
and
it's it's just uh yeah i think the more
eyes we can have
on the process the more open the data
are the more open that the uh
comments from the viewers are uh
i think that's going to be a really
positive thing so that instead of
putting this very critical decision on
the shoulders of
two people that can be continuously
reshuffled
we have more eyes on the situation and
we can develop
more of a consensus where many informed
people can look at it from many
different
informed perspectives and say uh you
know
yeah this is some really high quality
work here are some caveats here some
limitations so
from that perspective alone i think
there's huge benefits
with the open science movement i i think
uh i i think
having more eyes on the work and on the
data will allow us to develop a better
uh consensus and a better group
understanding
of exactly what those data mean and
exactly what they don't mean
and i think it would help
reduce ridiculous stories like the one i
just told right
where you're just like dude if you ran
this by people who had any interest in
it and any like
any perspective on this and it was more
than just like two people who just like
clicked except at 5am on the bus on
their way into work
uh we could probably avoid some of those
ridiculous situations
you know one of the things that i think
is
an interesting concept is the idea of
like
you mentioned pre-print servers right so
you do the research work
you put it on a pre-print pre-print
server and
now it's accessible for free and people
can can look at it
and provide feedback provide commentary
and i wonder
if that if that process
became more common and universities
would actually
give you credit as a researcher for
publishing a good preprint
at that point you wonder kind of what
the need is
for journals and for this very opaque
peer review process because
the work is out there and experts can
provide open commentary on it
so i think
to kind of put my perspective in a
nutshell when i think of the open
science
movement you can name many benefits of
moving toward a more transparent process
with more openness
not to mention just the ethical
consideration when someone makes
a very important health-related
discovery who's allowed to learn about
it
i think that's a really messed up thing
where it's like ah
i can tell by the title that there's
some critical information here that's
relevant to my health
but who's got 40 bucks to drop on it
right you know what i mean like that
that's a really
weird thing that paywall journals
make us wrestle with so yeah i mean i
can think of all these different
upsides in terms of the ethics and the
quality of the work and i
i can't really think of that many
downsides
in terms of shifting toward a more open
uh perspective
or an open process towards science and
so i
i'd like to consider myself to be a
pretty
open-minded guy so my question for you
is what is the downside like
when people take the opposite
perspective what is the most common
justification for saying no no we need
to slow down this open science thing
so there there are a few things um
one is a concern that i've heard
that i
like initially disagree with and then
log on twitter and then start agreeing
with is the idea that like if
uh if papers are too open
and like the quote-unquote unwashed
masses
have access to them that uh
you know they'll basically just do like
a
very poor job of interpreting those
papers and
wind up with with bad information being
disseminated
and therefore to improve the signal to
noise ratio
like you need like the quote unquote
experts
in the ivory towers to be the ones doing
the work be really the only ones who
have access to the work
who can give the like quote unquote
correct interpretation um
and and like i said i i do think that
that's
uh both like insulting and misguided
i i do see where it's coming from though
because
you know there there are times where
like
when a new study in fitness like sports
science is published
i will see some just like just
horrendous takes on social media
um or like criticisms of the paper that
people wouldn't make if they understood
how like
data collection worked um
so i i it's on one hand i do kind of get
that
that potential criticism but i i think
that the benefits of
uh of allowing stuff to be open still
far outweigh the drawbacks um another
another criticism that i've heard is
that
um
in this is like
kind of a theoretical criticism for open
data
the idea being that like if you have to
make your data
available when you publish your paper um
someone else might be able to snag that
data set
see like oh there is another
you know there is another hypothesis
that i could approach this data set with
and then write up those results as if
this was mine
and as if i collected these data um
and the thing is i don't i'm not aware
of any cases of that actually happening
of basically researchers stealing other
researchers open data
um but i also feel like that would be
a relatively straightforward process to
address um
especially if open data was the standard
because they'd have to share the data
that they correct yeah
so i i think that that is a theoretical
problem
if you're operating in a system where a
minority of journals have open data
policies
and the rest don't so you know you could
make your data
publicly available and then someone else
could publish from that data set
in a journal where the data is not
required to be publicly available
that could conceivably happen but if
open data did just become
the standard and someone else publishes
quote unquote their data set and it's
identical to yours you could be like
okay
come the [ __ ] on like i i see what's
going on here you know
yeah so i think that that's a potential
issue with the current system but
it wouldn't be an issue if if there were
systemic changes
you know i know that i put you in a
tough spot because i asked you it's
like debate team and you got put on the
the debate team that you didn't
necessarily agree with
so i asked you to make these arguments
but i think one of the interesting thing
about those arguments
is that it kind of operates under the
assumption that the current system does
a good job of preventing them
and it just doesn't you know so like
like for instance
the idea that only the the you know
ivory tower expert should be
you know handling this information and
disseminating it
well the ivory tower said that there is
a black hole in the center of the earth
but twitter said there's not and now
it's retracted at least
one person in the ivory tower right and
and one section editor took a peek at it
said well this is worth sending out to
reviewers
and two reviewers looked at it and said
yeah this is cool right but but like i
said that was in the period of two weeks
three separate papers that
the ivory tower let through and twitter
said dude are you kidding me
yeah and then there's like oh yeah we
can't really defend this
and then the other thing you mentioned
of stealing data i've actually
uh seen some very fascinating stories of
that happening
uh in the uh in the peer review process
so i've actually seen a number of
stories
there it's a pretty remarkable thing to
do in a bad way
like it's a pretty extreme case so it's
not like there's stories all over the
place
but there have been instances where
because the process is opaque
reviewers have looked at a paper that
they've been assigned to review and said
you know this paper's so damn good i
might just make it my own
and they reject it as the reviewer and
then they steal it
and publish it in a different journal so
they submit someone else's work
throw their name on it and there have
been instances where
some poor researchers have been sitting
in their office they open up you know
open up their their email and they say
wait a minute
that's my paper yeah you know so like
the thing that i find interesting about
those
arguments is that it it kind of assumes
that the current system does a really
nice job of preventing those things
and i'm just not sure that it does no i
i agree um
so there are a few more uh criticisms
of of the open science movement one of
them
um so this next
criticism isn't necessarily about like
the open science movement
leading to bad results
and worse quality of published research
but more
more like uh researchers wanting to to
not have as many threats to their
reputation so
one of the things with open data and
open code
is that if if if there's something wrong
with your data
not necessarily saying that you know
it's like fake data or something like
that but
you know just simply you collected data
you had a methodology for collecting it
and maybe you just calibrated a machine
poorly
you know and now your data sets open and
someone who also
has expertise with the equipment you
used to collect the data
can look at your data and say well i see
what happened like you have some weird
findings because
that machine was poorly calibrated you
know um
or if you make your code public this is
something you bring up all the time
um like there are uh
one of the most common softwares to
analyze like to do statistical analysis
in our field
is spss um because you don't have to
write code
for spss like as a point and click
software um
and there are certain analyses that like
spss just doesn't do like certain
interactions in post hocs that it it
just can't get at
and then people will say in their
statistics section like
oh we used spss and these were the
results we got
and you'll just like lean over and be
like
dude look at this [ __ ] they're they're
saying they did this particular postdoc
they used spss
i know good and well spss won't run that
post-hoc test or won't make that
comparison
and so the thing is like if code had to
be open like sps has this point and
click but it
it does also spit out the code that it
ran
um people could look at that and say hey
you said that you ran this post talk and
did this post-hoc comparison you
literally can't do that
in the software you said you used um
so you know maybe you just
misinterpreted the spss output
and so in a situation like that you know
nothing nefarious is going on like you
miscalibrated a machine
you misunderstood a statistical output
like those are those are innocent
mistakes that people make
but they would you know
probably necessarily result in a
correction if someone could look at the
code look at the data and say
hey there's a simple error here you need
to issue a correction
and one of the problems with the current
journal system now
is that issuing a correction is a huge
pain in the ass
um and so like you know
people i i think that there's a
thrust to not make that stuff public
because
if it was public more corrections would
just
necessarily happen and that's
that's more work for people who end up
needing to correct their papers and also
currently in i don't agree with this at
all but currently
uh having to issue corrections
semi-frequently is kind of seen as like
a black mark on your cv
um which which i think is not great so
you know if you have to issue
corrections for every paper you ever did
okay maybe you're not a very careful
scientist and
maybe that should be perceived as a bad
thing but you know if you have to issue
a correction on one out of every five
papers you published that would be seen
as an extreme rate of corrections
under the current system but also like
that seems perfectly reasonable to me
because you know like people make
mistakes
you know and maybe one out of five would
still be quite a bit but even like one
out of ten that would still be seen as
an extreme correction rate
and you know people make mistakes
sometimes and i
i don't think that making occasional
mistakes should be penalized but it
it currently kind of is in the current
system
uh and basically like open data open
code
there would be way more corrections that
would be issued
but the thing is like in other fields
that has actually been super super
important
um so one uh one
example in the field of economics is
a couple researchers reinhardt and
rogoff
published a paper um
basically showing that when government
debt gets too high
subsequent gdp growth over i think the
next decade
was slightly negative like there they
average like a 0.1.2 percent
decrease in gdp over the next decade
if if memory serves when government debt
was
more than 90 of gdp or something like
that
and so like that finding kind of became
the largest part of the evidentiary
basis
for like austerity uh projects that
various governments undertook after the
financial crisis
um but the thing was like the
the reach the researchers reinhardt and
rogoff like they weren't acting
maliciously
they're not fringe people like they're
they're big time
serious economists and they were using
an
excel sheet that their data was in and
when they did that calculation
they just simply accidentally didn't
like
drag down and select all of the rows
that they were supposed to
to run their calculation on so i think
there were like
18 or so countries in their data set
and they accidentally only selected 14
and when they analyzed the data from
those 14 countries
they found a slight decline in gdp if
government debt was too
high and when they selected all of their
data
they actually saw a 2.2 percent increase
in economic growth over the next decade
um
you know which just like completely
harpoons their finding
and i don't i don't have any hot takes
on government austerity like
i'm not an economist but the thing was
like
literally millions of lives were
affected by
that by that finding which was
a simple error like i don't think that
they that they were acting maliciously
and people found that out way after the
case
um you know i think the re the original
finding was in like
2006 2007 um
people basically like recreated the data
set and recreated the analysis
in i believe 2013 but a lot of the
austerity policies were put in place in
like 2008 2009
um so like you know that's something
that could have been
found and corrected in five minutes
if the if the journal that the original
finding was published in had open data
policies because it was
it was a simple xl error and that's
that's all there was to it
um and so yeah i mean that
that would have been a very momentous
correction
to have been made you know what i mean
yeah um so you you know this
statisticians follow me around in my
life there's some weird thing going on
every person i interact with is is
interested in stats so like
i took a horseback tour through the
smoky mountains once
and and the tour guide was a retired
statistician
so like i was riding through the
mountains on a horse just talking about
bayesian statistics like
so the reason i bring that up the guy
that i
have always coached with with special
olympics is also
you guessed it a statistician the one
lesson that he just burned into my brain
was listen eric you're a careful guy
probably too careful you should relax a
little bit
but if you ever make a mistake on a
project analyzing data
it's gonna happen in excel it's the data
entry
it's the data calculations before they
go into the stat software
so like you bringing that up is like
dude
when i collaborate with somebody on a
project i send them
a multiple page document telling them
how to arrange the data
but i'm like don't touch anything like i
like i'm going to handle all of the
any calculation it's script based we're
not dragging and dropping because people
mess up
drag and dropping you know but but yeah
so i mean that story is the most
believable story i've ever heard but it
like you said it's a great example of
if some of these processes were just
more transparent
it would have been picked up like that
right you know and and
could have prevented erroneous policy
from being put in place which is which
is really crazy
uh and then the the last common uh
objection that i hear
to the open science movement uh from
time to time
is just that it would
so some of the open science policies
would wind up being more work
so um for example
one of the things that's becoming more
and more common is pre-registration
of study protocols so i mentioned that
before
basically there are repositories where
you can say hey we're going to do this
study this is how we're going to collect
the data this is how we're going to
analyze the data yada yada yada
and so then when the paper actually
comes out people can check
you know the methods of your paper and
how you analyze your data
against the pre-registered protocol to
see
like hey did you actually collect this
data and analyze it the way you said you
were going to because one of
one of the problems with science
generally
is that when when researchers have too
much leeway
about how they collect and analyze their
data they may find that like
their primary actual hypothesis didn't
pan out like they didn't get the
statistically significant result that
they were looking for
and so like they find some other
significant interaction in their data
set
and then they write up the paper as if
that secondary thing was
actually what they were looking for in
the first place um
and like the null finding then goes
unreported uh and so
you know if you're doing a meta-analysis
or like a systematic review after the
fact
that that null finding isn't mentioned
anywhere but like
it sh you know it happened it existed
it should be included in a meta-analysis
that's
trying to look at all of the studies
ever done on the topic but uh
no one knows that the study was ever
done to actually
look for that primary outcome that was
never reported you know so so that's one
of the issues you can run into without
pre-registration
um just basically if you give people too
much leeway when analyzing data
they can find a lot of [ __ ] you know
and so one of the things with
pre-registration
is it is another step in the process and
there's
a lot of there's a lot of kind of like
paperwork and busy work that goes into
science you know it's not all just
you're in the lab eight hours a day
working with subjects collecting data
like you have to write grants you have
to
write up protocols to send to the irb
uh you have to write up your results
after they come in like there's
there's a lot of writing and a lot of
people don't like writing
and so if you're pre-registering a study
protocol
that's one more step you have to go
through before you actually begin data
collection
and also if you um
you can run into like some logistical
issues with irbs as well
so you know if you uh if you get the
protocol approved
and then you say okay like the protocol
set in stone by the irb
they've approved it now we're gonna
write it up for
uh like to pre-register the protocol if
the irb comes back
like you know let's say you had a
training protocol and
a couple of your people got hurt and you
have a very conservative irb
and they say hey you know we don't want
you hurting all of these human subjects
you need to tr you need to change your
training program that you're using in
this study
um it might look sketchy to go back
and register and like change your
pre-registered trial protocol
and like it would be completely innocent
like you're making a change that the irb
is saying you have to make
but people might look at that and say oh
these people are changing their
pre-registered protocol like
are there uh are there nefarious aims
here
um so in all of those things like it's
just adding another step into the
process
that i think a lot of people don't want
to have to deal with another very
comparable thing and
what i think is one of the coolest and
best innovations in scientific
publishing
probably ever is registered reports
so one of the issues i mentioned before
is
uh well i didn't mention it by name but
i
alluded to it is the concept of
publication bias
and so within the current system
journals are more likely to accept
basically like exciting findings and
exciting findings tend to be
statistically significant findings in
the direction that was hypothesized by
the researchers
and so if you have positive findings
like that
they just wind up being easier to get
published and like
just null results in general are harder
to get published
and so what you can wind up with is
is basically a body of literature that
is biased
in the positive direction towards a
towards a particular outcome just
because the positive studies are the
ones that are more likely to get
published
uh and oftentimes like you mentioned
psychology specifically and i think that
it's worse in psychology because the
studies do
tend to be a lot quicker easier and
cheaper to run
you know you can wind up with a problem
where no results
researchers don't even attempt to
publish them in the first place because
they know it's going to be a pain in the
ass to get them published maybe
they've said publicly that they believe
in
you know whatever statistically
significant finding they expected to
see so like null results might be
slightly embarrassing
and so you know you just wind up with
like a
skewed body of literature with way more
positive results and way fewer null
results than
have actually occurred so one o so what
a registered report is
is instead of submitting
instead of submitting the paper after
you're done with the whole project
you know after you've collected the data
after you've analyzed it and written it
up
and then submitting it instead of that
it's basically like pre-registration on
steroids
you write up your study protocol you
write up your data analysis protocol
you submit that to a journal and they
in the journal says this looks like a
cool and interesting study that you've
proposed
we like your methods your method of
analysis seems
sound regardless of what the results are
they will be useful and relevant
to the people in this field who will
read this journal
and then they accept your paper and then
you do the actual experiment
the data come in you analyze them and
the papers already accepted
so you know it will get sent out to
reviewers again
because you know maybe your discussion
section is just batshit insane and
they're like
okay you need to tone down the
discussion but the paper itself in
principle
is already accepted and so if you get a
null finding
it is already published you don't have
to worry about the journal rejecting it
so it helps it helps completely
eliminate the problem
of positive publication bias
but again going back to the problem
people have with open science of it
being more work
you know now instead of submitting a
paper once you're submitting it twice
and i would argue that on net it
registered reports actually save effort
um
because basically you're probably going
to deal with fewer rejections
of uh of null findings like you know
you mentioned like having to submit a
paper to eight different journals and
just reshuffling until you get reviewers
that
are good or who like you um
and and when people do that it could be
nefarious like maybe they just did a
very very dumb stupid study that
shouldn't get published and they're just
fishing for reviewers who will accept it
or it could be that they did a very good
careful study
that had no results and just like
reviewers keep rejecting it because
they're like ah this this is [ __ ]
boring we shouldn't accept this
um and so like i do think on net it
probably
does save time because you know you get
the paper accepted on the basis of the
protocol itself
um but it does add one more step that
you have to go through before you
actually begin data collection
um so that that's another reason that uh
just like various steps in the process
where
effort is added that's that is a
drawback
uh and i mean i i don't think that
that's an
adequate reason to reject open science
because you know ultimately if it's more
work but you wind up with a better body
of literature that
seems like it would be worth it but
there is also kind of a lot of busy work
that goes into science in the first
place and so so i understand people not
being super stoked about it yeah and i i
do know
quite a few people who are editors of
journals like associate editors
and so they're the person with the job
of tracking down reviewers
for a paper and i would bet that
you know despite what you mentioned in
terms of reducing the number of
total projections potentially i would
bet that a lot of associate editors
they hear the idea okay i gotta get
reviewers
to review the methods and then review
the finished product and they're like
absolutely not because like yeah dude
every friend i know that's an associate
editor
like every six months they just like
send out a tweet saying like
no one reviews papers anymore
[Laughter]
they're so sad because like they keep
sending out all these papers to get
reviewed and
everyone's like i'm not gonna review
that yeah and so i i bet the editors are
a little bit nervous about the idea of
having to get a pay-per-view
twice do we want to also talk about how
stupid the idea of uncompensated peer
review is
sure i mean it seems pretty
self-explanatory right yeah
dude so this is something that people
who haven't done any science may not be
acquainted with um there's a good
question to ask
of what do journals do
like what value do they add um
and i can't tell that they actually do
in any way whatsoever
so you know basically you have
uh an editor-in-chief of the journal and
there are there are so
associate editors or section editors
and theoretically how the process tends
to work is papers are submitted
the editor-in-chief takes a peek and
they say like okay
like just looking at the abstract this
is a paper that
like the subject is germane to the
interest of this journal or it's not
and if it's not they say oh well this
might be a nice paper but submit it to
another journal because this isn't
really
what we publish if it is something
that's
you know within the scope of the journal
they'll send it out to
an associate editor or section editor
and say like hey
this is your problem now uh this kind of
seems to be like
this seems like it would fit in the
section that you edit um
so take a look at it see if it's worth
sending out to reviewers so the
associate editor will take a peek
you know not do a full review but just
basically determine like is the quality
of this work
worth sending out to reviewers or not
and then they find a couple of reviewers
they send it out to the reviewers
and the reviewers really do the vast
majority of the work
uh they're supposed to essentially go
through the paper with a fine-tooth comb
you know make sure that the the method
section makes sense
make sure the results are reported
accurately
make sure so theoretically a reviewer is
supposed to make sure that all of the
sources you cite
are correct and support the points
you're making
i don't think they do it most of the
time okay because i see
so many miscited papers uh but that's
theoretically something reviewers are
supposed to do and basically like a good
review
is supposed to take a long long time um
like i mean one of the basically our job
for mass
is peer reviewing papers that have
already been published and we don't
write up mass articles as if they were a
peer review but we
look at them as critically as we would
if we were peer reviewing them and then
you know try to break break the study
down in
in a way that's going to be accessible
to people um but i mean i can tell you
like
every paper reading it with that
level of like concentration and detail
like it takes hours
hours many hours yeah and uh
and peer reviewers aren't paid like that
peer review is a completely
uncompensated endeavor
for you know a job that might take you
five or six
hours for every paper you look at um
which to me is just batshit insane
and so we've talked about issues with
the peer review process
if you want to check out an interesting
paper
richard smith who was the longtime
editor of the british medical journal
he wrote an article called peer review
colon a flawed process at the heart of
science and journals
uh that's worth checking out that goes
through
a lot of the the issues with peer review
and just like problems that peer
reviewers miss
coming from someone who was a journal
editor who
relied on peer reviewers for a long long
time saying like
look the peer review system doesn't work
very well
and the thing is that i'm not throwing
shade at reviewers here because like
you shouldn't expect it to work well
there's no
there's no incentives that would
that would cause you to predict that
peer review would work well
basically the the incentive for
doing good peer review is the pride of a
job well done
uh and then the cost is tremendous
opportunity cost because the better job
you do the more time it takes
and uh you're not being paid for your
time
and you have a lot of other [ __ ] on your
plate you know and so like
yeah it's not surprising that most peer
review
like most peer reviewers don't do a good
job
kind of through no fault of their own
because why the [ __ ] would they do a
good job
you know um and so like ultimately
the peer reviewers are doing 90
of the work that the journal is doing um
they're not getting [ __ ] paid for it
and the people who
are making money are like the actual
publishers so
you know if you uh if you subscribe to
jscr journal of strength and
conditioning research and you see that
like
william cramer was the long time editor
bill kramer didn't get rich off of
editing
jscr like no journal editors get rich
off of
editing their journals like a lot of
them are uncompensated and the ones that
are compensated aren't compensated much
uh like wolters kluwer is the publisher
for jscr
wolters kluwer is making the [ __ ]
bank off of it um and so like
you know not just the reviewers like the
editors also aren't getting paid
much if any uh there are copy editors
that get paid which
you know is why you don't see like that
many typos in journals
um but yeah like there are copy editors
and typesetters that get paid
uh most other people who are doing the
vast majority of work in the process
don't see a [ __ ] dime for it um
and so like yeah no [ __ ] peer review
doesn't do a good job
uh do you wanna do you wanna go through
um some of the things people will say
like to argue against
compensating peer reviewers because
in my opinion this is the funniest [ __ ]
yeah let's go for it
so one of the criticisms i've heard
or the the argument against compensating
reviewers
is it's just simply too sweet of a gig
so if you compensate reviews
for these papers then people are going
to take on a ton of reviews and do a
terrible job so that they can make more
money
and just do a bunch of very superficial
reviews um
they're going to be laughing all the way
to the bank because of the scheme
they've got going on and there is
no way to possibly handle that or deal
with it
or reduce its likelihood of happening
that that's the one that i've heard that
is is pretty wild because like greg you
know
we operate in the real world we have a
business
when's the last time you thought you
know we need the service done but
if we pay someone to do it i think
they're going to do a way worse job
yeah they'll do a worse job if we pay
them for it
and we as intellectual dumbasses
could not possibly ascertain whether
they did a good or bad job
and if they do a bad job we will have
absolutely no choice but to continue to
hire them
to keep performing that service over and
over again
like dude that's
not how any of this works yeah it's dude
like
the the uh the response to that
potential
issue is literally as simple as
set a price point that makes any sense
at all
and just make sure they did a good job
someone already has to do that
like you already have an editor who's
determining if they did a good job or
not
if you find someone who's taking on a
ton of reviews and doing an awful job
you just flag them in the system and say
hey don't uh don't send them papers
anymore
yeah and you know if you have someone
who
is accepting every review that comes
across their desk
getting paid for it and doing a really
really good job
like cool let that person get [ __ ]
paid
you know you'll wind up with a system
where a disproportionate
number of the reviews are going to
people who do a disproportionately good
job of reviewing papers
oh what a [ __ ] problem you know what
i mean like
dude and it's so it's ridiculous too
because i know we've mentioned this on
the podcast before but
but scientific publishing is such a
racket like it's it's a system where the
people who do
virtually all of the work don't get paid
for it
um but they're kind of like peer
pressured into doing it because
you know like theoretically it looks
good on your cv
if you've done a lot of reviews it looks
really good on your cv
if you've been an editor or associate
editor for a journal like that's
uh that's part of like the service
requirement
that comes along with most academic jobs
so
you're not being forced to peer review
and you're not being
forced to be a journal editor but like
there are
there are ways that you're strongly
cajoled
into performing a lot of unpaid labor
uh in the publication system and
so the people doing virtually all of the
work aren't getting paid
a cent for it and the people who
actually own the journals
are are working with absurd profit
margins
um so like el sevier's profit margin is
close to 40 percent
springer nature's profit margin is like
north of 35 percent
uh taylor and francis 30 plus wolters
kluwer 30
plus like all of the major publishers
have very very very comfortable profit
margins
and the thing is like they're
making enough money to pay reviewers
like
they could put more into the system so
here's the problem with like journals
primarily being for-profit enterprises
like if
uh if they were basically being run as
services which
which is how it used to be actually so
if you go through the history of
scientific publishing
what used to be the case is that
basically
um scholastic societies would say like
hey we're interested in physics
and you know we're going to put out
a journal that that details findings
that our society members have made
we're not going to run it for profit or
like if there is profit there's not
going to be much
and then uh this dude named robert
maxwell who is just like an all-time
piece of [ __ ]
uh he had already like made a fortune in
magazine publishing
and was basically just like what if i
used this exact same model
um but all of my workers were dumb ass
academics who didn't expect to get paid
and i could like
peer pressure them into doing all of
this work for free and basically use
the increasingly less profitable
magazine model to make bank off of these
dumb ass academics that don't understand
how the real world works
and like very very cynical move worked
like a [ __ ] charm
he built an empire off of it he made a
ton of money from it
other people said wow maxwell's model
works really really well
we're gonna do the exact same thing uh
and like
you know so in the span of a couple
decades
these people who like didn't actually
care about science
uh realize that they can make a quick
buck off of completely changing how
publishing works
they did it and like now that is by far
the dominant model
in the market um and you you explained
this to me
a few weeks ago and i was stunned at the
time frame in which it occurred about
when did did this
transition occur i'm pretty sure it was
like immediately post-war
yeah and so people people act like
you know public is if you talk to any
researcher they do have complaints about
the publication system
no one likes it but they're like you
know this is just the way things are
it's the way it's always been and it's
like nah dude like that's not how things
were up until world war
ii and then like immediately post world
war ii people said let's make bank on
this and it
just completely changed the way that
publishing worked yeah because
you know i was in academia and everybody
would complain about it but everybody
would say well it's just
always been this way and there couldn't
possibly be a different way
yeah i would have thought that that was
the system that has literally existed
since the dawn of time
i had no idea um but you know there is a
little anecdote that kind of
puts all of these topics together so a
couple months ago for mass i was
reviewing a paper
it was a meta-analysis and one of the
cool things about meta-analyses
is the data are more or less
open whether you want them to be or not
you know so like we
talked about having open data sets for
original studies
well with a meta-analysis your data is
the published literature
so it's open right and so you and i are
we work together most days we're sitting
at the computer and i was like
i literally opened it for the first time
i was like check out this error
you know what i mean like 30 30 seconds
into opening the paper
and so uh looked into it of course it
was an error it was a huge error
that just screamed and jumped off the
page
and it was a journal that actually
publishes the the reviews
open access so it is kind of a step
toward that open science model
you can actually read the reviews you
don't know who wrote them but you can
see what the reviewer said
and dude like two out of the three
reviews were a sentence
i mean a sentence or a couple sentences
um not a single comment about the
methodology not a single question hey
how come what happened there you know
like yeah and if you had ever seen
a forest plot or a funnel plot in your
entire life
and considered what it was telling you
the first thing with the review is
you'd probably like honestly you'd
probably email the editor and be like
come on
why'd you send this to me yeah but at
the very least in the review you say
what in the world happened here
and it was a perfect microcosm of the
fact that
open science matters and allows us to
detect errors that might cause us to
make
inaccurate conclusions but right now the
safeguards in the peer review process
are not there the reviews we're getting
are not
adequate and why would they be
i mean there's also the question now
we're getting into the topic of like
predatory journals
there's also the question of whether
those reviews actually happened
uh because you know it very well could
be that the journal
did not send it out to any reviewers and
they just like
you know the associate editor just typed
up like two sentence reviews like
i'm not saying that happened but uh
i think that that does i mean that does
occur like that's what predatory
journals are they claim to be peer
reviewed
they're not actually peer reviewed like
you submit a paper
you pay the author fee and then
a week later you say like or like the
journal will email you say
hey we sent it out to reviewers the
reviewers said this was
tip top work your paper has been
accepted yeah um
so i mean that does also happen yeah
based on the reviews these reviews
definitely happened
but but you could tell it was one of
those things where it's like
you know we've sent an email out to a
bunch of people
they all declined we found someone to
say yes
that person who said yes dude academics
they work hard yeah so this is a person
working 70-hour weeks just trying to
you know just trying to make it in the
academic world
and on top of their 70-hour week we've
asked them to
very thoroughly review this and look for
every possible error that could exist
uh and sign off on it and they probably
did it at five in the morning or one in
the morning or
you know 11 p.m after they put their
kids to bed
and it just it was like yeah it was like
a sentence or two just like i guess it's
fine
you know so it's it's an issue that i
think
open science uh would certainly help
with
yeah so uh you know i
i have been uh i've been
playing the con position on this so far
you uh
you talked about some benefits you asked
me to talk about issues that people have
with it
i think it should be clear i think that
the problems posed by
open science um
are so much smaller than the benefits
you actually
gain from open science uh i think that
i i think that that a lot of the reason
why science isn't more open i think
there's
a lot of institutional inertia um
you know people have been operating
in the sciences in a particular way for
the last 30 years
and a seismic shift towards open science
would
you know basically force them to change
a lot about how they do things and i
think that
a lot of the older people
not necessarily like trying to be ageist
about this but
they're the ones who have more
experience within the current system
and it would be like in and they're the
ones who have who tend to have the most
like institutional power
and so i think that there's a fair
amount of inertia from
kind of more experienced academics who
don't want to make these shifts
i think that i think to some degree
the the reluctance towards
shifting to open science um
might be driven by fear
almost um so this is something we've
talked about before
like very
it's pretty uncommon that like a data
set is perfectly clean
that like every you know every less
last instance of data collection went
perfectly smoothly
and i think you know i think a lot of
people just
i i think that there's a lot of uh
oh what's it called the um
not the bystander effect
what's it called when basically you
think everyone is better than you the
imposter syndrome yeah yeah i think that
there's a fair amount of imposter
syndrome where
you know people are doing generally good
work and their
their data set is like 95
good but like they know that like uh you
know maybe there were a couple errors in
data collection like maybe i have some
missing data
and i don't want to put my data set out
there because you know
then i will be the emperor without
clothes and people will see that this
data is not as clean as i could make it
look in my results section
and they don't realize that like
everyone's data would pretty much look
like that
yeah and so i think that there's some
some resistance
especially towards open data for that
reason um
well in one comment there you mentioned
there might be errors in the data
collection but also like consider this
if you listen to this podcast you
probably lift have you ever
misgrooved a rep yeah do you think that
completely untrained untrained people
are more likely to misgroove a rep
and if your outcome is reps to fatigue
and they had three left but they
misgrooved one really bad
set's over right you know what it means
to like the idea that there's noise in a
data set
isn't just oh we botched it and the
machine malfunctioned that that
certainly happens but yeah i mean dude
people miss groove reps and sometimes
it's during the testing visit
right and like that [ __ ] you got to deal
with yeah and it is what it is you know
yeah
uh so yeah i mean i i think uh
i think the benefits of open science are
enormously larger than than the
drawbacks to it
i think that the current system is i
wouldn't say
completely broken beyond repair but i
think that
it is incredibly easy to conceive of a
publication system
that would just be better way better
uh on every conceivable level um
and i think that just institutional
inertia is is the main thing
holding us back right now yeah and there
is an
organization called stork uh that that's
kind of leading the charge
pushing more people in the field of
exercise science and kinesiology toward
more of these open science methods yeah
it stands for
uh society for transparency openness and
replication
in kinesiology yeah so i think the good
news is you know
we've just spent an hour talking about
uh the various
benefits of this open science concept in
this movement and i think
one of the really positive things that
we can put in there to kind of wrap
up the conversation is that people in in
our field
are are kind of leading the charge there
and and it definitely looks like there's
going to be some progress made
in the years to come there's some really
really smart really solid people behind
that
that organization so should be good
stuff on the horizon
for sure a rare instance of eric trexler
with the optimism
[Laughter]
uh do we want to push forward or is this
just
a fireside chat about open science uh
let's do
let's give the people something a little
bit lighter let's skip right to the end
and talk about our most hilarious gym
fails sure
i feel like that would lighten the mood
a bit yeah i can uh i can lead this one
off
yeah go for it so i'm pretty early
in my training career i've talked about
this on the podcast before
uh some of the folks i trained with were
big time west side guys and that was
that was my introduction to powerlifting
and
these these folks uh kind of took
louie's ideas and cranked them up to 13.
so you know basically like max effort
day was max effort day
dynamic effort day was a max effort day
but with
an enormous amount of band tension and
then you would like do the speed work
um and they you know basically took what
louis said about
hey bands are good for all of these
various reasons
and and the thinking was essentially
well if bands are good more bands must
be better
so we used an ass load of band tension
on pretty much everything
and um so once upon a time
uh we were doing rack pulls and we had
just gobs and gobs of band tension and
i was if memory serves
the only person in our group that pulled
conventional
uh or no no no there was one other
conventional puller but he was like five
five
um so i was the only like average height
person who pulled conventional
and so we were doing rack pulls and and
the
i'm not just like height flexing right
now this will be relevant
um we had got probably like
five six hundred pounds of band tension
on the bar just like
multiple doubled heavy bands uh and it
was like fairly high rack pulls as well
and so it wound up
being like most people were working with
like a four
inch range of motion and i was working
with like an eight inch range of motion
um and as we were warming up uh
you know we were we were doing reps and
the the power rack we were working out
of wasn't bolted down
and you know we were in like the actual
cage part of the power rack and there
were weights on the back of the power
rack
but obviously they weren't providing a
counterbalance against
a lifting force on the front of the rack
and so
as we're warming up with all of this
band tension um
i did a rep i stood at lockout for a
second
realized like wait a second why is the
bar
continuing to feel lighter in my hands
and it's because like
the band tension was sufficient and i
was just
tall enough that it it was like
basically lifting the front of the rack
up off the ground like the the
tension of the bands pulling against it
um
and so like this was a big ass power
rack and it just tipped it backwards
uh there was a mirror behind the rack it
shattered the mirror
uh it was a cinder block wall the rack
was like tipping fast enough that it
like
pretty significantly chipped some of the
cinder block
um and then basically like the whole gym
had to be rearranged for like two weeks
to get the rack away from the wall so
that repairs could be done on the wall
and then like the gym had to pay for
another mirror and like mirrors aren't
cheap
um and this was also like
5 p.m so it was peak gym time
the whole thing was full like i i was
14 maybe 15 at the time
so like i was i was the only like young
teenager in there and there's just like
all of these adults glaring at me
disapprovingly
and in hindsight i'm not like that
embarrassed about it because
i wasn't the person who decided to do
like heavy tension
block pull or heavy tension rack pulls
and like
it's not my fault that i was the only
like average height conventional
deadlifter in our group
it could have happened to anyone but at
the time i was completely mortified
and that that is far and away the most
uh destructive gym fail i've ever had
yeah so fortunately my gym fail
wasn't as destructive but it definitely
had the potential to be
in terms of human cost uh
so you know if you ever like watch a
documentary about like old rock stars
and they're like hey what happened you
know this particular event and they go
well it was the 80s and there was a lot
of cocaine around
so my story goes back to the late 2000s
and there were a lot of pre-workouts on
the market um
dude you remember the late 2000s every
pre-workout was just like
what is the most intense pre-workout
that we could make without killing
someone
yeah yeah or with only killing a few
people yeah numbers were way more
limited than
the scare-mongering mainstream media
would lead you to believe
yeah it's not like gym goers were
dropping dead left and right
but it's also not the gym goers weren't
dropping dead
right yeah and i mean like yeah it was
it was pretty messed up
but uh yeah it was the late 2000s um
i was obsessed with lifting at the time
it was the only thing that i actually
was interested in or cared about
um and yeah so i i was on the campus of
a university i
i don't want to get anybody fired so
i'll leave it vague which one
but i think i think they just forgot
that there was this gym that existed in
a basement
of a dorm i don't there's no way they
knew about it
there's no way so like when i say a gym
i mean
you open the door and there's a bunch of
free weights in there
there's no front desk there's no staff
there's no checking
it's just a room with a bunch of metal
in it
and i just there were no windows you
know so i went down there
at like two or three in the morning and
was just like
i got a lot of energy i'm all hopped up
on pre-workouts
let's just go for it and so it's like
you know three a.m
no one around no windows in the basement
of a building no one could hear you
scream
and uh dude i just like pancaked myself
with a one rep max
bench like with clips on the bar
oh there was no tipping it like i i
probably like you know not to be
dramatic i probably could have just
rolled it down but
it was like a good 98
of my max that i just barely missed
grooved and i just got pancaked
and uh as i could feel this happening i
was like
you know when i say pancake it was for a
split second like i was
pinned and i had the only
genuine honest-to-god fight-or-flight
response that i've ever experienced in
my life
and if you've never had a real one it's
wild
like i really believe that if there were
twice the weight on that bar i still
would have got it
the the the intense fight or flight
response like
i was pinned and then the bar was up
it was the wildest thing i've ever
experienced i've never experienced
anything like it so
it was a potential gym fail and then
after it i was like
what am i doing down here like that
could have been a really a really
unpleasant night for me
that uh it's [ __ ] scary dog
yeah so i i haven't i i haven't had
anything
that scary happen um
but i tore a peck uh
doing some some benji centrics i believe
with 495.
um so you know it was like super max but
not like
crazy super max like i i think my max at
the time was like 465 give or take
uh but it was definitely more that than
i could push off of me and it was
definitely more than i could push off of
me with a torn pec
uh and it was one of those like time
dilating things
where you know i feel i feel the pet go
i'm like this is a problem and then i
stopped to consider
i don't have a spotter uh this is an
even bigger problem
and like it it felt like 30 seconds
between when i could feel the the pec
let go
and when i was just positive my
impending demise was coming
and you may be listening to this and
thinking greg why were you doing
eccentric bench without a spotter
it's because i had [ __ ] pins up uh
like
you know i was just doing eccentrics to
the pins this was like my fourth set
i knew the [ __ ] pins were there uh
but it it was kind of like that same
fight or flight response that you were
talking about
if you've ever played a video game with
bullet time mode that's what i felt like
i was in because
it couldn't have been more than a
quarter second between my peck letting
go
and the bar making contact with the pins
but that quarter second felt like
it was a minute and a half and i was
like i don't have a [ __ ] will
like how long will it take for people to
get here to pull this off of me
uh the music's really loud if i scream
is anyone going to hear it like there
was enough time for all of those
thoughts to go through my mind and then
it's like
clink clink what the [ __ ] it's the fins
and i felt so [ __ ] stupid um
but like i i was i was shook like i had
a wild
fight or flight response like i went in
the bathroom
and my uh like my pupils
were like my eyes were just completely
black because my pupils were completely
dilated
uh it was the craziest feeling yeah it's
pretty wild man
well i tell you what we uh we're
probably about at the end here right
yes sir uh so thank you for listening to
this
episode of the stronger by science
fireside chat
uh fireside chat series if you
enjoyed it uh leave us a rating on
itunes or wherever you get your podcasts
uh if you're listening on youtube give
us a thumbs up drop a comment
that does help with traffic to some
degree if there are
any questions that you'd like to hear us
discuss in a fireside chat
or if there are any lifting questions
you'd like to hear us discuss
uh on a regular site or regular stronger
by science podcast if
eric ever wants to have me back as a
temporary guest co-host
you can ask those at tiny dot cc
slash sbsqa and uh that's about it
hope you are enjoying life staying safe
and we will talk to you again soon
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast
now greg and i are not experts in
medicine or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor or another health care
professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit
strongerbyscience.com to check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you